ancien athlète de haut niveau pierre
rigal découvre la danse contemporaine
tardivement il fonde dernière minute sa
propre compagnie en 2003 le spectacle
érection marque le début de sa carrière
la même année un solo important pour
l'artiste qu'il éprouve toujours le même
plaisir à jouer est toujours aussi le le
plaisir de pouvoir
physiquement le jouer parce que c'est un
spectacle assez physique et donc il ya
13 ans j'aurais jamais cru pouvoir le
jouer le jouer autant aussi longtemps je
veux dire et donc je suis agréablement
surpris de voir que le corps semoule
dans un spectacle devient devient
relativement intelligents ce spectacle
propose une réflexion sur trois versions
d'une même tentative d'érection celle de
l'homme animal de l'homme individus mais
également de l'homme social
le solo met en scène le passage de la
position couchée à la position debout
les lumières définissent quant à elle
les frontières du corps organique de
l'environnement et de l'image en jeu
d'intersection des différentes réalités
l'idée peut paraître simple comment se
lever mais en réalité je me suis rendu
compte en pour en préparant ce spectacle
qu' il y avait une infinité de
possibilités entre cette position
couchée cette position de bouc le
personnage s compte obtenir que l'on
agrémentant plus par un dispositif de
lumière de vidéos très particulier qui
crée donc des illusions optiques sur sur
le sur le corps de ce personnage depuis
le 21 novembre 2003 date de la première
du spectacle 192 représentations ont été
données dans 22 pays différents
ce soir mercredi 6 avril pierre égale
sera au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines